hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in chapter nine of his treatise on truth
anselm is going to revisit some of the
matters that he talked about earlier in
the treaties
specifically
action and truth in action and
signification
and he's going to connect the two of
these together in ways that by the end
of this chapter are also going to be
bringing in
other modalities of truth as well
showing how
they are
interconnected and he starts out by
saying to his student who's in the
dialogue with him we're going to talk
about how broad latta in latin
is the truth of signification this is
the key topic here is it just in
things that were
used to calling signs like language
or
you know gestures or things like that
or does it extend to other matters as
well and he says that it's not just in
the things that we're accustomed to call
signs as and in a certain way you could
say
what this means is that
the things that we call signs aren't the
totality
of signs that is things that are
significant that things that tell us
something and so he he tells us
that um
truth of signification
is in all other things
of which we say there is true or false
signification now you might say well
wait a second we've got truth in
signification and then he talks about
truth and thought and maybe that's
including signification or they're
connected in some way but then we've got
truth in the will and truth in action
and truth in the existence of things or
the being of things so i i don't know
about that those are different kinds of
truth and anselm says well no because
actions
are also
significative how do they signify things
and here he doesn't mean like well an
action signifies a certain emotion like
i give you flowers and you say oh that
means you love me or you know i sing a
song on your birthday happy birthday to
you and then you're like oh
you remembered my birthday the action is
significant in that way no he means
something a bit broader
every action
in so far
as it can be judged as something
that we ought to do
or ought not to do we're doing what we
should or what we shouldn't do
is either true or false according to the
previous chapters right and
a person ought to do he says what they
ought to do quote debit so
when a person does an action
they're not just either you know doing
what they ought to do or not doing what
they ought to do being judged in
accordance with some sort of whatever we
want to call it a rule a norm or
something like that
they're also saying something
by the very fact
that they're engaging in that action
they're saying something to
themselves and about themselves they're
also saying something to anybody else
who is witnessing that action by doing
something anselm says
they
signify it is a sign
that that's something that they
ought to do that thing
that action right so if i to use the
examples that i had before
if it's your birthday and i don't sing
happy birthday to you or remember it
anyway
then i'm actually sending a message as
we say and the message might be well
you're a jerk and i don't like you or it
could be i don't celebrate birthdays but
it's also a broader thing like i should
behave that way i behave that way
because i in some respect
think that that's the right thing to do
or
maybe i don't think it's the right thing
to do but i do it anyway and on some
level i'm saying that this is the right
thing for me because it's an exception
there's a lot actually built in here
that anselm is not saying explicitly but
we could easily read in there so by
doing something
by engaging in an action a person
signifies that they ought to do that
action now here's where it gets really
interesting
is it true or false
and we can say well you know a person
could be misguided oh don't worry about
that
worry about whether they should or
shouldn't do that action because whether
they're misguided that's a whole other
modality over here
if i
punch you in the face randomly on the
street i am asserting by that very
action that that's the thing that's okay
to do that's what i ought to do and that
is false i shouldn't do that so if the
action is what we ought to do then we're
telling we're signifying the truth
if not we are lying even if we don't
open up our mouth even if we don't type
anything even if we don't
write anything right the things we do
our truths or lies
depending on whether they are what we
ought to do or ought not to do and we
could be lying even if we think wrongly
that this is the way that a person ought
to behave so this is a very
complex
uh
connection or interconnection of truth
and lies that we're dealing with here
and he's got this great example a really
interesting one he says imagine
that you're in a place and you need to
pick some herbs
and you don't know which ones are
healthy
and which ones are poisonous or you know
literally going to give you some sort of
plague right some sort of illness
but there is a guy there
and this guy
he actually knows which herbs are good
and which herbs are bad
and let's say that this guy
he
tells you hey those herbs over there
those are the good ones
and then he goes over here and he picks
other herbs now anselm says
what are you going to believe are you
going to believe what this guy says his
word verbum in latin
or are you going to believe the action
he's engaging and presumably he's not
going to pick bad herbs for himself he
knows which herbs are good
and you know he's going to pick these
good ones for himself and he's going to
leave you the poisonous ones while you
go over there and you pick the good
herbs because you can be sure that he's
you know he's actually asserting on some
level without words just by his actions
which ones
a person ought to have and we could you
know think about this in many different
ways if
a person
is saying you know you shouldn't cheat
on your partner
that's really terrible i think that's
you know morally reprobate okay well
that's actually a true statement but
then you look at their actions and they
cheat on their partner you're like
what do they actually believe
their
actions are asserting that in some way
it must be okay to do this or at least
it's okay for them you know it's okay
for them to violate the norm that they
think everybody else should be following
and they are lying in their actions in
two different ways right by cheating on
their spouse they are doing something
that they ought not to be doing but
they're further asserting that this is
what they ought to do they might be
asserting it to impressionable
other people like children
right who they set a bad example for the
children don't know any better and they
see that they should behave this way or
think about people who abuse each other
and you know could be with invective it
could be
uh with you know physical violence or
something like that they are sending a
message
that this is
okay or even how one want to act and
it's a false lying message according to
anselm
he has another very interesting example
what if a person lies to you
now here we're talking about truth and
lying in an even more complicated way
right this is you could say
meta lying isn't it because
when a person lies to you if you didn't
know that lying was wrong
you would be
getting a false message
about you know telling the truth and
lying and they would be giving that to
you again we could think about the
example of children and how they can be
misled he says if you didn't know that
one ought not to lie
and someone lies to you even though he
told you he ought not to lie he would
tell you by his deed his action
that he ought to lie
rather than by
the word that he ought not and and some
goes a little bit further than this
imagine
that we could see the thoughts
or the willings of a person
now you can't actually see the thoughts
or willings of a person the person
that's you right and you can to some
degree
infer what the thoughts or willings of a
person are when they communicate them
when they say i'm choosing to do this
here's my decision-making process or
i've been thinking this in a lot of
other cases though we have to judge by
what a person does the actions but
imagine for a moment you could look into
their head and see
what they are thinking or
willing anselm goes on and he says
when someone thinks or will something if
you did not know whether he ought to do
or will it
if you could see his will and thought
they would signify to you by the deed
the action of willing or thinking
because these are all actions of the
mind
that he ought to think or will this so
if somebody is constantly thinking
things like how can i cheat my neighbor
and make a ton of money
and you find out that that's what
they're thinking
that is significative it is an assertion
on their part this is what people ought
to think about or at least what i ought
to think about
and it's a lie because it goes against
these norms of what you ought to be
thinking or willing or whatever other
cognitive thing we could talk about
loving you know anselm doesn't bring
this up but people love or desire
certain things hate or avoid other
things maybe we're wrong about those as
well he goes on to say even the
existence of things the being of things
asserts in a certain way
that they ought to be
so
this is really interesting when we think
about that because it doesn't just
pertain to
individual things like this piece of
chalk ought to be white which is true
right i mean
this one ought to be white if it's
colored it ought to be colored
it ought to you know have a certain kind
of texture to it be usable on the
chalkboard we could go on you know
further from that
but we can say about states of affairs
is it really the case
that some people ought to be
so poor that they have no place to live
and cannot reliably feed themselves and
are subject to the you know violence of
other people out on the streets or
is that in a certain sense
a lie
anselm would probably answer that
by saying that is kind of a lie in
certain ways and we could go on and on
and on so thinking willing even the
existence of things these all fall into
the other things which we say there is
true and false signification so the
realm of signification truth and
signification is indeed
considerably broader than we thought
encompassing action which also
encompasses so many other things as well
so
truth in these different multiple modes
is indeed
quite complicatedly
interrelated with the other modes of
truth
you